at the end of the day there were only  two abstentions and the CDU party  meeting gave the expected resounding yes  to the coalition agreement despite  concessions to the SPD Chancellor Merkel  said it was a solid basis for a  government yeah why yes there's a good  chance that Germany and its citizens  will be better off in 2017 than they are  today there was a surprisingly lively  debate about the contents of the  coalition agreement younger delegates  and the party's economic wing expressed  concern at the SPD's core demands  including a statutory minimum wage and  pension benefit increases as fact  honestly these compromises aren't easy  the right to articulate the problems we  have with several points 911 if the SPD  approved the coalition agreement it  could be signed in a week